so we'll talk about the dichotomy
fingers for counting constraint
satisfaction problems and I think they
would refer to thunder I would probably
call it like a hammer result like it
does a lot of power you can use it to
hit a lot of things but it's not like
very delicate there are things that you
cannot explain which will see it about
the end of the talk but i would just
flush through all these definitions
which we have seen multiple times so
just just to make sure we're on the same
page about the notation so d is the
domain and a language is just a set of
relations and the instance of counting
constraint satisfaction problem is
something like this you have a bunch of
variables and you can apply relations
from the language on these variables and
the decision problem asks whether it's
empty or not and there were these
examples and there are these different
problems we can ask you know decision
optimization including the valued
constraint satisfaction problems with
weights and we're interested in the
counting problem in this talk so the
same set up the only difference is that
we're interested in computing the size
of our how many typos are there that can
satisfy all the constraints and these
are the corresponding counting problems
and we can generalize it to include
weights so now the language consists of
functions given an instance we can
define a function over m variables which
is just take the product of other
constraint functions and our goal is to
compute this partition function which is
the sum over all possible assignments
and the counting graph form of muffin
problems or petition function we talked
about is the very special case when L
consists of a single symmetric and
binary function and the unweighted
counting CSP is the special case when
the function when every function takes
01 values we have these sequence of
dichotomy theorems for counting CSP so
the first dichotomies by NJ bullet are
four for the cannon CSP unweighted
counting CSP and the it's a typical
dichotomy theorem every such problem is
either solvable in polynomial time or
shall be complete and then we have an
alternative proof by dire in Bitra p and
a feature of the proof is it gives an
alternative tractability criteria which
is equivalent to the original one but
can be now shown to be decidable in mp
and then it was further extended to non-
rational languages by bullet or friend
oh and then to non- algebraic languages
and then with GE we proved the dichotomy
theorem for for the languages including
those with complex weights
so here is the plan of the talk I was
spent I think most of the time like
eighty percent of the time to give you I
think a pretty detailed proof of the
dichotomy theorem for unweighted or 01
CSP counting CSP and most of the time or
we're going to focus on the y aguas
impart because that's that that turns
out to be the most difficult part
compared to the hardest part which is
very different from counting reform
offices where I think on this part is
more difficult compared to the y aguas
impart so we'll talk about the Chuck
bility criterium and techniques like
polymorphisms entry talked about in the
morning we'll see one particular example
called much of polymorphism and why
having such a pond morphism helps you
get a very useful algorithm and then
we'll see what we can do to extend it to
non- and even complex valued accounting
CSP so let's start with a very simple
definition we have a non-negative matrix
and we say it's rectangular if if you
can basically perm you the rows and
columns and make it blog Rank 1 make it
look like this and every blog every
entry in each block is positive and
equivalently you can define it as the
following you can take any choose up to
x 2 sub matrix of this bigger matrix and
you know if this two-by-two matrix has
three positive entries then the other
entry must also be positive so just note
here that we don't really care about you
know the values of the entries or we
care about is which entries are positive
and which entries are 0
in the next condition or next definition
we care about the entries and we call
non-negative matrix block rank one
matrix if it is rectangular and in
addition every block is the rank one
matrix so for example this is not a
broad rank one matrix because this is
not rank one you have to you know fix it
to make it block rank one matrix and
then the talk i will use the picture
like this to you to denote block rank
one matrix as we will see in this talk
we're interested in mostly matrices like
this like very skewed we have a lot of
rows but only little D many columns
little D is the size of the domain and
these will be the blogs each one is
positive and rank one and outside of
these blogs it's all 0
and now let's talk about the
tractability criterion and state the
dichotomy theorem so here are some of
the matrices we're interested in in the
definition of strong balance the
tractability criterion so let's fix the
language that we're interested in and
now take any CSP instance and then you
get a relation the instance defines the
relation let's say over m variables now
you partition the variables in you know
in 23 house you know let's say the first
k variables is part 1 then you have the
next l variables and the rest are
variables and then it defines for us a
matrix m the rows of the matrix is
indexed by you the K double columns are
indexed by V at El Chapo and the UV
entry is the number of ways to complete
this sub 0 to make it a string at a bow
in the relation R so it's a non-negative
integer and that's that's the matrix m
so there were a lot of you know infinite
too many such matrices because you have
infinite in many instances and you can
also pick the any partition you want
here is the first condition called
strongly rectangular and a language is
strongly rectangular if every such
matrix you getting this way is
rectangular matrix and the second
condition stronger is says that every
such major exists block Rank 1 it's
rectangular and it's also block Rank 1
now the condition of strong balance
equivalent to congruence singularity
using bullet Ofsted caught me theorem
it's also pretty clear that strong
balance implies strawberry angularity
and you catch reconstructing example to
show that it's not the other direction
and now we're able to state the
dichotomy theorem in more details in
bullet of dichotomy theorem I shows that
you know if the language is congruent
singular then it's in p I can solve it
efficiently otherwise it's shall be hard
and the later able shown that if it's
strongly balanced by diary in which obey
and then they'd simply otherwise it's
it's Sharpie home now the hardest part
of the proof is relatively simple
compared to the the algorithm part I
basically do a graph gadget reduction
and have a reduction from the graph of a
morphism problem over a non-negative
matrix to this CSP and then show that
this matrix is actually violates the
condition of bullet of growth it has a
two by two sub matrix that's not rank
one
so we're going to focus on the algorithm
part of the dichotomy theorem which says
that if you have language that is strong
strongly balanced then I want to use
this property to give efficient
algorithm so here is the first technique
that we're going to use which is
polymorphisms that Android talked about
in the morning and here i mean the
definition i restrict this map to be
tolerated because that's all we are
going to use in the talk so just repeat
the definition polymorphism is the map
such that here you can take any three
strings in the relation and then you can
do this operation you know component
wise you apply the map and you get a new
couple in the properties that this new
topple should also be in the in the
relation if the original three tuples
are in the relation will see this
picture probably such a picture like
three four or five times in the talk
just just because I I think at the
beginning when I first see this
definition like I have complete no idea
what's going on even today I don't think
I I can use it whether still don't have
a very good understanding but hopefully
after few examples we can see that when
you have a language that has
polymorphism at least the problem often
that we're going to see the course so
called much of polymorphism it gives you
some very useful efficient algorithms
that can you can be used to understand
relations so what is the match of
polymorphism it's a polymorphism but in
your dish turn it just is satisfy this
condition which is like the opposite of
majority so when you have a BB the
result is a and when you have BBA the
result is also a that's the only
condition on the polymorphism and this
shirt out for or a B including like a
ecorse be more generally we say language
has much up on Marxism see if it's a
it's a polymorphism multi-point morphism
for every relation in the language
no just let's do some exercises about
you know much of polymorphisms and and
get better at it so the first here is
the first observe a shin that's proved
it if you have a language gamma and
[ __ ] is upon much of polymorphism then
I claim that you can you know construct
any CSP instance and get a bigger
relation and this bigger relation should
also has to see as as a matchup on
muffin so for example let's say this is
the CSF CSP instance and I want to prove
that the same matchup on muffler should
also work for this this relation okay so
by definition you just take three tuples
that are in this relation then we apply
the march of polymorphism component
voice now I claim that the result should
also in the relation because we can look
at each of the constraints individually
so let's focus on the first constraint
we know that these three tuples are in
the relation so you are you to you three
should satisfy the relation we rerun v2
v3 should be in the relation the same
for W so I'll forget about the first
component after applying the merger
polymorphism these three entries should
give me a couple in the relation theta1
and you can do this for each of the
constraints and can conclude that this
is also a top of that is in the relation
R that satisfies all the constraints
now the other thing is the following two
things are actually equivalent gamma is
strongly rectangular is equivalent to
gamma having a much of polymorphism so
what this tells us is that okay we we
are working on the algorithm part so we
are assuming that gamma satisfies the
strong balanced condition which implies
strong rectangular ET and by this serum
we would know that gamma also has a
match up on the muslin and actually you
can assume that you're given this much
upon morphism because the language is is
a finite fixed thing you can't read go
through all the possible maps and check
whether one of them is a mojet pony
muffler now they will of course two
directions we need to prove here I'll
just do the easier direction the other
is more difficult much more difficult
than this direction but at least we can
see you know what's the connection
between these two so the easier
direction says let's say gamma has a
much of polymorphism see and I want to
show that it's strongly rectangular so
remember what's the definition of strong
rectangular it means that you can take
any CSP instance and get a relation R
then you just do a partition of the
variables into three parts using let's
say K and L now here is what we need to
show we want to show that if a
two-by-two matrix sub matrix of this
matrix m has three positive entries
let's call them u prime V UV and UV
prime then the other entry u prime V
prime should also be positive now what
it means for an entry to be positive it
means there is a way to complete this
trouble to get us doing in our so
this is what we can say about u prime V
now we can put something here so that
it's in art we don't really care about
these w strings for the same for UV and
the same for UV prime and actually it's
it's you know you should be careful
about how you put these what's the order
you put these three springs now then you
just apply the march of polymorphism and
you should get a new string that is also
in the relation and buy the property of
the mulch upon matheson the first entry
should be u one prime so we will get u
prime and then we'll get V Prime so we
know that u prime V prime also has a way
to you know concatenate something and
get a toppling on so u prime V prime is
also a positive entry and as a result
this matrix should be rectangular
now the next thing is that when you have
a relation that has emerged upon
Matheson there is actually a highly
sixteenth way to encode this relation
and actually this this representation
can help you answer a lot of questions
about this relation but to get there
let's just understand the relation that
has a mulcher polymorphism a little bit
you know deeper so let's say our is a
relation that has see as a pouch of
polymorphism so we're interested in the
projection of our onto the ice
coordinate you just it just contains all
the elements in the domain that you can
that has the string in the language
sorry in the relation and has the ice
coordinate being a and later will
actually naturally I mean it's not very
natural to cause such a string a witness
that a is in the projection of our on
the ice coordinate will cause such as
during a witness for this fat then we
can define this relation over the
projection and two elements a and B are
in the relation if there is a way to
complete a you know put something on the
left and put something on the right you
get a string in our and there is also a
same same thing you can do for B and
they actually have the same you know j
minus one prefix
the ww prime can be different can be the
same it doesn't matter but as long as
you can put the same prefix before a and
before B and get something in the
relation then we say a and B are in this
relation here is an important number
that will lead us to the succinctly
which says that if our has a match of
polymorphism then this is actually an
equivalence relation and let's just use
the same picture again to prove this and
the goal here is let's say a and B are
in the relation B and C are also in the
relation we want to show that a and C
are in the relation hey just just
plugging the definition what does a and
B in the relation means is that there
are these two strings with the same
prefix and bouncing the relation art for
B&C there are also these two strings
with the same prefix and there in the
relation R and you you prime can be
different in general then you just put
these I think three of them in the right
direction so in the right order so you
AV followed by ub v and u prime BW and
in the first part we would get u prime
then we would get a followed by some w
string so what does this tell us this
tell us that there is a string start
with u prime a and it's in our we also
know there is a strain you prime C that
is in our so by definition it tells us
that a and C are also in the relation
and this is the equivalence relation
which will see that plays a really
important role in the whole proof
now here is the really important
definition called witness functions I
think your first used in dire and
Richard be and it's similar to the
compact representation used in bullet
off and demo and the point is it's it's
highly succinctness you just need
polynomial many bits to describe this
witness function but on the other hand
it basically contains all the
information about a relation art and
actually it can in polynomial time tell
you something you cannot directly
compared to using our so
with this function Maps appear an
integer between 1 and n basically a
coordinate index and an element in the
domain to either a string n tap oh oh
neil and the first line two lines
basically tell you that if a is in the
projection of are on the ice coordinate
then Omega I a sorry if it's not in the
projection then Omega I a should tell
you that by by setting this entry to be
new and if it's in the land inglot
projection then it should give you a
witness you should give you as a typo in
the relation and have its eyes
coordinate being a so if i have a such a
function at least i can tell very
quickly whether you know what is the
projection on each coordinate very
quickly you just look at those entries
which entries are near which entries are
not now this is really important
property which we only you can ask
something like this because of you know
this is an equivalence relation so this
condition says that if a and B are in
the same equivalent class then these two
witnesses for a and B respectively given
by given to you by the witness function
should share the same i minus 1 prefix
so so what does the witness function
look like first of all if you have let's
say I a and a is not in the projection
then it's always new ok now for those in
the projection because we have an
equivalence relation we can divide them
into equivalent classes and four strings
in this for four elements that are in
the same equivalent class their witness
function their witness should share the
same prefix i minus 1 prefix
and this is a lemma which tells us why
you know it's it's so useful the first
lemma says that if I have a witness
function for relation R then you can
basically throw away this relation R
because I can answer membership queries
using this relation if you give me any
pent-up oh I can tell you whether it is
in the relation or not and it's very
useful because this relation is in
general I mean has arity n but on the
other hand witness function basically
contains roughly speaking n times they
OD many tuples so it's much shorter than
say the size of the relation now the
second lemma says that the attacker can
compute something for you very
efficiently that that not clear how to
do it otherwise so again we have a
witness function but now we're given the
string we're given a t-top oh you and it
turns out that we can use this witness
function to tell whether this top o is
in the projection of our onto the first
tee coordinates can tell you whether
there is a way to complete a top o using
this as a prefix and protecting the
relation R
and here is how you how we prove these
two llamas let's focus on this one and
it will become just natural like you
know it implies that you can also do the
same algorithm to get the slammer so
let's say I have a string I have a sorry
I have a type of work up switching back
and forth between taco industry so I
have a top of you and I want to know
whether it's in the relation or not
let's do a round by run thing the first
round we want to check whether you one
is in the projection of our onto the
first coordinate or not and if it is a
case i want to find also a witness and
this is really easy if we're given a
witness function you just look at this
entry one you one if it's neil we
already know it's not in the projection
if it's not new this entry is actually a
witness so after about one we should
have top o that is in our and its first
entry is you want and let's call this
strained u 1 V 2 and then W the key
comes round two will do the same thing
but now for coordinates one and two I
want to tell whether you know u 1 u 2 is
in the projection of our onto the first
two coordinates or not if it's not i can
already reject if it is I want to again
find a witness funk witnessed tempo
which is ER and start with you one and
YouTube
so the first thing we would do is to
look at this entry of witness function
to youtube if it's not if it's new we
can already reject if it's not new then
we can look at these two streams omega 2
u 2 and Omega 2 V 2 and they if they
have different first entries so what we
get from these are two tuples that are
in our and we compare their first
entries if the first entries are
different it tells us that you to you
tell us that you want you to cannot be
in the projection of our I'm to the
first to current coordinates because if
it is if it is in the projection then u
1 u 2 is in the projection u 1 V 2 is
also in the projection then you two and
v2 should be in the same equivalent
class they are equivalent in the second
coordinate and by the definition of
witness functions these two couples
should start with the same entry
so if it is this case we can also reject
the only case left that is that we have
two strings to tapos here and they start
with the same first entry let's call
them w one and then you two and then
something else and w1 you too sorry w 1
v 2 and something else and then you just
run the same same put these three
strings in the top one in the right
order and then apply the merch of
polymorphism and we would get a new
string in our let's start with you on
YouTube so in this way we not only know
that u 1 u 2 is in the projection we
also have found a witness for that and
all we need to do is just repeat for I
think anyone's to prove the first lemma
if we want to prove the second limoges
vp40 ones so this is why having a
witness function is is very useful but
where does such a function come from
suppose I have
so they have a language with the match
up on most muffin MC and I'm given a CSV
instance which defines the relation R
according to what we have talked so far
having a witness function would be great
would definitely help and this lemma
tells us that you can actually construct
one very efficiently in polynomial time
so I will not be able to give the proof
here it's it Tess I think about two
pages roughly speaking you start with
the empty instance with no constraint
which you know just trivial to construct
a witness function and then you just add
constraints one by one after adding each
constraint you update the witness
function to get a new witness function
for the instance with this new
constraint and repeat until you get the
CSP instance here
so with this we can now give the
algorithm so remember this is the go
this is the assumption we have a
language that is strongly balanced and
because it's strongly ballast is
strongly rectangular so we have now chef
polymorphism and now we have a CSP
instance let's say with unbearable and
this is our is the relation that this
instance defiance and we want to you
know compute the size of our let's
define these functions where f bracket T
has T variables and the value is just
the number of ways to complete it and
the gathered a boring are can think
about this these f bracket key functions
like you know some over the last
variable and then some over the minus
once variable of course I will go is to
compute something like f bracket zero or
f bracket one but on the other hand at
the very beginning what we only have is
you know how to compute how to evaluate
f bracket n which is just this relation
and as I mentioned earlier it's actually
very helpful to view these functions as
as each as a matrix so we'll view f
bracket T as the matrix with the e to
the t minus 1 rows and only d columns so
the rows are indexed by you know t minus
1 suppose the columns are invest index
by elements in the domain and the entry
is just the value of F bracketing
and just notation wise our also use app
bracket TX start to denote the row
vector index by X where X is t minus one
couple
so the main counting out wisdom uses the
following data structures so for now
it's not clear where these data
structures come from we'll build these
data structures later but let's assume
for now that for each f bracket t we
have a data structure which you can
query and we'll give you something back
very efficiently so for f bracket t you
can send t minus one tuple x or you know
you can send a row index here to the
data structure and the data structure
returns the vector which is zero if this
row is 0 otherwise it returns you
something that is now 0 and linearly
dependent with the vector that you're
interested in it may not give you
exactly that vector but will promise to
give you something linear dependent with
the vector and it turns out that with
these data structures we can compute
let's say f bracket one of a one very
efficiently then using you know the
definition we can get the size of our
very efficiently again the subways and
bronze round-by-round so we want to
compute F bracket one of a one so
clearly I want to I would be very
interested in F bracket 2 and the a-10
for example if I know this vector then I
can just do the song and get what I want
I have this data structure for F bracket
T so i can send this this row index
which is a one top of a one and this
data structure as promised earlier would
return the vector V if b is 0 then i
know this whole vector is 0 and this
would be 0 otherwise i get a vector V
which is now 0 and its promise
to be linearly dependent with the vector
that I'm interested in so take any
nonzero let's say the first nonzero
entry of this vector and we want to
compute the sum of entries from this
vector but we only know V then you can
just get this equation which we know how
to compute this using V and it reduces
the computation to evaluating f bracket
TF Market to at a1 and a2 you have two
linearly dependent vectors you want to
compute the sum of the first one you are
given the second one I can be reduced to
computing you know one of the entries in
the first vector you can repeat exactly
the same thing now I want to compute F
bracket 2 a1 a2 naturally I would query
the data structure for the row index by
a1 a2 and I would get a row vector that
is the linearly dependent with the
vector that I'm interested in and the
same argument reduces to evaluating this
entry of F bracket three ok so the keys
thing is that the branching factor is
one every time we want to evaluate let's
say an entry of F bracket T we can make
a query on the data structure for T plus
1 and then it reduces the computation to
evaluating one entry of F bracket T plus
1 and doing this for everyone's it
surfaces for us to compute to your value
8f bracket n and this is just you know
deciding whether this tableau is in
relation R or not it's one if it's in
the relation 0 otherwise and this we
know how to decide given the input
instance have the input instance you
have a particular assignment it's easy
to decide whether it satisfies all the
constraints or not so this is the main
counting algorithm and clearly the best
of the proof is just to to say you know
when it's strongly balanced when the
language is strongly balanced we can
actually build these data structures
very efficiently and then combining
these data structures with this man
counting hours and we would get the
track ability part of the proof
and so how to view these data structures
here is the first observation because
the the language is strongly balanced I
already know that these matrices are
block rank on matrices because these
matrices are just special cases of the
matrices we discussed in the definition
of strong balance the special case when
the second blog has lens one has only
one variable so this is the picture for
block rank point matrices we have a few
blocks at most D of them and the rest is
0 furthermore it gets closely related to
the equivalence classes of this
equivalence relation so let's let's take
this block the screen one and let's say
the columns are 1 2 3 take any row index
here X which is a t minus 1 topple then
we know that all these three entries are
positive what does it mean it means
given x + 1 you can complete it and get
us tapo in the language with x2 you can
also completed and get at Apple in the
language which tell us that one and two
are equivalent under this equivalence
relation just by definition and this
towers actually all these three should
being the same equivalence class and it
also holds the other direction if you
have an equivalence class it should give
you columns of one of the blocks so
there is a natural one-to-one
correspondence between equivalence
classes of this relation and blogs of
this matrix so each equivalence class
corresponds to columns of one of these
blocks
and the next thing is that it's not only
that each of these blocks are positive
they're ranked 1 right because they rank
1
all I need is to kind of store one of
the row vectors here and whenever a
query comes in if I know this query
belongs to the screen vector the spring
block then I can just return that vector
I start for you that that vector would
be linearly dependent with the row
vector that you're interested in okay so
this is what we call a representative
vector for each block and each blow
corresponds to an equivalence class so
let's say we have a representative
vector V J for each equivalence class EJ
so representative vector is just a
vector that is linearly dependent with
you know all the row vectors in the
corresponding block and I claim that
once you have computed a representative
vector for each of these blog or each of
these equivalence classes the data
structure is ready whenever you have a
prairie I can answer that Perry I can
give you a provide vector very
efficiently in polynomial time so how do
you do that whenever we have a query X
let's just decide you know which blog it
belongs to or maybe it belongs here you
know it's all 0 now to decide for
example whether it belongs to the green
block let's say I want to know where the
X belongs to the Queen block or not all
I need to do is to check whether x1 F
bracket TX 1 is 0 or not and as if
that's the same as asking whether X 1 is
in the projection of our onto the first
tee coordinates or not that we know how
to answer using a witness function for
our so we can answer this very
efficiently repeat this for each blog we
can tell which blog it comes from or it
doesn't come from any of the blogs if it
doesn't come from many of the blood
which and 0 otherwise we return the
representative vector for that block
so this finishes everything almost
everything we want about these data
structures which tells us that all we
need is to find a representative vector
for each of these blocks and store in
the data structure and whenever a query
comes in we can you know decide which
vector to return the last piece is just
two beauties data structures backwards
one by one so let's start with the data
structure for 4f bracket and this is
easy because I know how to evaluate this
function efficiently it's basically just
the relation R so first of all using the
equivalence class I can you know compute
other equivalents sorry using the
witness function i can compute other
equivalence classes now for each
equivalence class let's say this one you
can use the witness function together
witness temple and then just evaluate
the whole row index by X and use that
role as the represent a representative
vector you can use this this role as the
representative vector for this blog and
this takes you know d evaluations of the
f bracket n function which is you know
affordable because we have the input
instance if it is exactly the same thing
for f bracket t first of all figure out
the equivalence classes using the
witness function then for each
equivalence class just evaluate one row
here and use it as representative vector
the only difference is that we don't
know how to directly evaluate f bracket
t compared to f bracket n but it turns
out that you know you can using this
basically the same counting algorithm
but assuming that we already have access
to data structures t plus 1 through n
you can actually evaluate f bracket t
efficiently earlier I showed you how to
if
you ate up bracket one if I have to
through em but the same thing house if
you have data structures 40 plus 1
through n and you want to evaluate f
bracket T now this really completes
everything about the output some parts
of the dichotomy theorem for the
non-negative CSP it turns out everything
here can be generalized to get a
dichotomy theorem for non active CSP and
eyes you know the algorithm just works
exactly the same the only difference we
need is that we need to also to extend
the strong balanced condition so we have
now a non-negative language and here are
the functions here are the matrices that
we're interested in take any instance we
get the function and again partition the
variables into three parts and we get
this matrix the only difference is that
instead of counting you know how many
w's together top o er which is summing
over all the w's here
and the strong balanced condition said
that every such matrix should be block
Rank 1 and if that happens the language
is solvable in polynomial time otherwise
it's it's shall be hot so I have 10
minutes but that would use that to give
you some ideas behind the US dichotomy
for CSP with complex values the first
difference is now we have cancellations
and this is the observation where things
start to become a little bit little bit
different so take a take a
complex-valued language and take an
instance we can define this relation you
know x ser if and only if FX is non zero
now we only can account is a non zero vs
0 and similarly we can define this
function f bracket t which is just sum
over all the variables except the first
tee variables now the difference is that
in the non negative or zero one case
given a witness function for this
relation R I can use it to tell you know
efficiently whether this entry is zero
or positive once I have a witness
function but now I cannot because even
if I have some nonzero entries here I
may get cancellation this is this some
and this entry may still be 0 okay
but we will still use the main the same
counting algorithm based on the same
data structures it's exactly the same
data structures given a query the data
structure returns in polynomial time a a
type of a row vector that is either 0 if
the vector we're interested in is all 0
or return something non 0 and linearly
dependent with the vector we are
interested in and the same cowboys and
would go through once we have built such
data structures so here are the
difficulties in building such data
structures so the first thing is we may
need to start a lot of representative
vectors so I in general if you have if
you have em by D matrix it could be the
case like every two rows are linearly
independent so if we want to store all
the representative vectors like if
suppose you want to stall a vector a
bunch of vectors so that every vector in
this matrix is linearly dependent with
one of them you may start you know the
whole matrix which is too is too many
because we may have D to the t minus one
many vectors and here is the hint from
the works on counting Gruffalo muff isms
where we have talked about you know
matrices with pairwise orthogonal row
vectors these are basically large out of
the tractable cases and the wishful
thinking is what if we can impose the
condition that every two rows of this
matrix SF bracket key either linearly
dependent or orthogonal if that's the
case at least you know number wise I
only need to start at most D many
representative vectors and it turns out
that we can actually impose this
condition
because we can show that if the language
violates this condition then the problem
is already shabiha okay and the next
thing is okay this what we talked about
sync to simplify the picture a little
bit now we only have at most D many
blogs each blog has you know pairwise
each block is like Rank 1 the next
question is how can I answer a query so
let's say our primary comes in to answer
this query I have to tell whether it
belongs to the red blog or the blue blog
or the yellow blog or it doesn't belong
to any blog if I can also that I can
return the corresponding representative
vector but it's not clear how to answer
this question but what if all these sets
each of these sets each of these SJ has
much of polymorphism if that's the case
and if we can compute witness function
for each of these sets that we can use
the witness function to answer queries
membership queries like these so this is
the second condition the the match of
condition which requires basically that
all such sets should have a witness
function so it should have should share
the same mochi of polymorphism and again
if it violates this condition then the
problem is is shall be hot
so we're almost there we know how to we
know how many representative vectors we
need at most D we also know that if you
can compute a witness function for each
of these blogs the data structure is
ready so the last piece is how to do the
backwards induction you know compute
this these vectors and then the witness
function is forever racket and move on
to F brackets and minus 1 and do this
one by one and it turns out there are
some technical difficulties like we
don't know how to do that unless
assuming this condition which roughly
speaking allows us to manipulate
relations that share much of
polymorphism and that we can afford to
make this assumption because again
otherwise the language would be shall be
hard and with this condition we can do
the induction efficiently so putting all
the things together the block orthogonal
erty condition tell us that so they were
only at most the deep blocks the match
of condition tells that you can if you
can compute a witness function for each
of these blogs you can you can use them
to answer membership queries and the
type petition condition tells us how to
build these data structures these
vectors and witness functions one by one
backwards so the theorem says that if
the language satisfy all these
conditions then the problem is in
polynomial time otherwise if it violates
any of these three conditions it'sit's
Sharpie hot so this is everything about
the dichotomy and here is the thing i
said earlier like why i feel like it's a
hammer because because it's not as
explicit as you know counting graph or
more muffins and it's not as it explicit
as dichotomy for non-negative CSP so if
we're given a language and we're
interested in deciding you know whether
this language which case this language
falls into whether it's easy to solve or
how to solve
all the graph form amorphous on papers
have a very explicit condition which you
can just follow step by step and check
whether it's easy to solve problem or
hard problem for non- CSP it's a little
more difficult but it's still in NP and
for the complex ESP it's we don't even
know if it's decidable or not and just
says to part like what we know I don't I
think we don't even know whether this
condition is necessary or not for
example I don't have an example where
you know this condition is violated and
you have to make impose this condition
and this is genies take I think this was
three years ago but I don't know where
they have updated the sonnet and the
other thing is whether it's possible to
apply some of the ideas they are
somewhere like Holland problems or
approximation CSP I have no idea how
whether this is doable but they would be
cool if some of the things here can be
extended thanks
oh yes since another incarnation you're
saying it's not known to be decided by
or which ones are not said not on to
decide the last one none of them ring
ring they all apply to a clock if you
will set
the matzav one is it a little like you
but how does the matzo one differ from
stroke a motive
because of the cancellations zeroes in
the matrix
rather than might be tuples that have
wait 0 because antenna solutions do I
mean evidence may be precise
secret probably I would pare down that
it's disciple but dr. know how to quiet
well I hope it's decided be kind of cool
if it wasn't if we can prove it's under
seven yeah that we think a pretty cool
wishes
like this break